you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the following is a presentation of the
st. Louis chess club
players from 14 nations converge in st.
Louis as US chess champs calm presents
the third annual spring chess classic
[Music]
hello chess fans and welcome back to st.
Louis for round number three of the
spring chess classic my name is Ben
Simon and along with me is Grandmaster
Amon Hamilton whose hair is looking
fabulous today well it had to be better
I just had to had to bring my a-game to
the commentary booth with you in order
to compete my goodness what a horrible
lie that was well anyway we have an
exciting day for you you know no one is
in clearly than either the a or the B
fields but as you can see on us chess
champs calm we have three people atop
the field in each division let's take a
look at our group a Liam Lee an alien is
Nick and Aria and tari sitting at one
and a half points each they are at the
top and then the rest of the field just
close behind really anybody could still
win this what is your assessment thus
far Aman of what we've seen from Group A
well obviously near the bottom of the
standings early on you can find Vasily
Ivanka who along with the rusyn Kasim
Janna those are two guys you definitely
don't expect to find near the bottom of
the table you know early on you start to
wonder is that age showing or is it
another factor but those guys are gonna
be looking to to really make a bigger
impact on the tournament and you know
like like I said it's not nice to see
the Canadian bringing up the caboose
their pens so hopefully he can turn the
tournament around it's early stages
hopefully Erik's age isn't showing as
well alright Group B let's have a gander
at that a similar situation only we do
have someone who hasn't scored at all
that is that FM Alexi Sorokin at the
bottom who could be and I am and was
looking and still is looking for a GM
norm in this field ginchy by Nicholas
Theodore Oh Gregory cat Donna all have a
point in half today and actually two of
them are going to be playing and that is
our go to match
in Group B any thoughts on Group B thus
far well I'm pretty impressed so far
with with by Jin cheese play and also
Gregory Qaeda I've had a really nice
game as he took out korilla yesterday so
I'll be looking to see what he can do
with the white pieces because I thought
that he played a really nice game and
otherwise by June she has the top seat
has been looking very solid if you're
just joining us we'd like to introduce
you to the tournament format these are
game in ninety games for the first forty
moves that is and then thirty minutes
added on for the rest of the game there
is a thirty second increment from move
number one so you're not gonna see too
many people run out of time although we
did see it once in this tournament
thirty move draw rule is in effect to
encourage fighting chess that means that
no players can agree to a draw before
the thirtieth move and all the players
are getting to that just about now here
in the schedule you'll see that each day
the round begins at 1:00 p.m. at u.s.
chess champs calm and we are on the air
two and a half hours afterward at 3:30
p.m. all except for the final day to
make room for playoffs if necessary we
encourage you to follow us on YouTube
that we've got the chat open today and
we'll be answering your questions and
looking at your comments if they're
worthwhile that is and also on us chess
champs calm who knows maybe I'll glance
at the chests 24 chat as well it's going
to be a fun day let's take a look at the
pairings these games are already
underway in Group A alien is Nick vs.
Werdum Kazin jonov Vasily ivanko vs. Ray
Robson Benjamin buck vs. Jeffrey Zhang
Erik Hansen versus liam lee and our key
matchup today re ontari vs. varoujan
Akopian
the two of the leaders not the leaders
but two of the top scorers in this field
will be playing and let's take a glance
at where they are so far in this game
come on actually uh we're here in this
game and honestly Ben I've I've never
seen such a slow moving game Akopian has
15 minutes and they're on move 13 and if
and he plays the French all the time and
tari based on what I'm seeing is not
playing a line that is first of all
extremely challenging to the French not
playing a line that the bar has let's
say not seen before so I'm stunned a
little bit by the by the pace of this
game because with 15 minutes left 30 for
Atari here with the white pieces we're
gonna be seeing a time scramble almost
for sure so so I mean taking this from
the start because that's not very far
away we see that actually it's a
relatively topical line that came out of
this opening and this B six move by by
var is in place of let's say B five is
another another option for black here
but again all of this stuff there's even
c4 in some lines for example of white
long castles there's c4 but b6 again I
don't know really what's taking so long
other than you know just double triple
checking or trying to remember theory so
it's a little bit confusing me the
amount of time spent but speaking about
the position okay Knight c5 was the last
move played sometimes you'd like to play
Knight to e4 one thing we can
demonstrate is that if white okay let's
just make a pass if black takes here
oftentimes white wants to take with the
pawn which might not look normal because
you know why would I take with the pawn
when I could take with the Queen and
play see three and just secure my bishop
but I actually want to take with the
pawn here in order to control these two
squares play in the dark squares and if
I can you know move like Queen here try
to put these pawns on light squares and
a sample variation let's say something
like this if I can trade off these dark
square bishop I might have a real idea
to put this knight on d4 and this Bishop
of b7 is so bad so there are some dark
square ideas of you know playing on
those squares here for white so I think
that that's a possibility here if you
take but of course var probably knows
better he's probably gonna go for more
stuff more like this and of course you
always have that f6 break for black
sort of chip away at that Center
meanwhile white is gonna bring this
night into the action of course he's not
gonna play King each one you might but I
don't think so
and he's gonna bring that Knight into
the action you always have this f5 move
looming but with when blacks attacking
the bishop here you can't really get
away with that five for the moment so I
mean that seems like the top priority
right now I mean there's no doubt right
next move that the Knights gonna take
the bishop on d3 well again for VAR it's
it's that that bishops not going
anywhere so so he doesn't have to do
that which is the nice part about this
position for black if you know white
goes here again Bishop e2 allows me to
play 90 force or a game time and it also
removes that Bishop from the nice
diagonal so if I saw white maybe play
this move
c3 he would be playing and play Bishop
c2 then I might take that Bishop exactly
as you described but if the position
stays like this I think var can remain
flexible he can start with Bishop d7 he
can start with f6 maybe Queen c7 a lot
of very decent moves for black and he's
got that bishop in his back pocket if he
ever wants to take it so I don't think
he needs to rush with that in a matte as
a matter of fact I think structurally
taking on d3 and allowing white to play
pawn takes is actually not what what
black wants to do so I think he might
hold off on that and as we see tari
thinking here about what he wants to do
whether he wants to get that night back
into the game usually going crazy with
like g4 f5 is a little bit too much in
positions like this it's it's kind of
asking for it so I don't think he'll go
crazy like that but rather the knight on
d1 needs to re-enter the game I think
he's he's looking for whether he wants
to play 90 f2 or Knight e3 it seems well
it's uh it glanced over to group B where
just moments ago we had our first result
oh wow let's take a look at the stand or
nothing the pairings in Group B right
now if we have them we know that in
Group E Andre bars pullets is playing
Stein Crimson mm-hmm we have Sergei
Arenberg versus Christian korilla we
have Nicholas theodoro versus Dennis
Catterick this game actually just
finished into theodoro just put cabbage
I haven't gotten a chance to take a look
at that game yet and Alexi Sorokin
versus Alexander Mista and then our key
matchup of the day which I do want to
look at briefly before we potentially
have an interview here
Gregory Kay Donna man he looks happy
there's this by ginchy who is so far the
star of this event but remember these
guys are both at the top of this field
one and a half points each so what's
going on in Group B well we've got this
game in front of us right here
bhaijan sheep playing black Gregory CAI
Donna playing white and I think most
notably is just somebody somebody
started vacuuming the chessboard and all
pieces are gone this is like the
opposite of the game we just looked at
some guys are on move 13 some guys are
almost done their game so first of all I
don't think that I need to look very
hard at this to say that objectively
it's probably drawn that being said you
you have to look at the space advantage
which is in Black's favor you have to
look at the clock advantage usually
tells the tale but who's more
comfortable with the position also in
blacks favor you know is that enough to
win it shouldn't be but let's say if I'm
seeing anyone win this game it's it's
got to be black but I don't think I down
a player like like him is gonna have too
much trouble in a position like this
looking a little bit deeper at the
position in terms of moves well f4 was
the last move played by by black here
and one thing you never want to allow of
course is any time that you take you
never want to take back with the H pot
because then black would get this
outside pass pause so as long as you can
always take back with this pawn then you
have some ideas for example if we just
make a random move and I try to create a
way that you know maybe we could think
about losing it might be something like
this where you get an outside pass pawn
maybe Knight check take the pawn just
some sort of disaster scenario but
obviously a cation of his is not going
to be falling for any shenanigans like
that but that's really all he's got to
be concerned about there's a space
advantage but I'm
sure that it's gonna be decisive here
but by ginchy with a big time advantage
big space advantage the better place
pieces we look at those nights he he's
the only one to me that can win this
game yeah it looks like I could very
well be a draw because both players do
have a lot of time on the clocks yeah so
a lot of a lot of trades going on I
suppose a lot of trades there's almost
no more pieces to trade but they're
gonna hit move 40 I mean I dunno if I
don't think time pressures gonna play a
factor in this so objectively I'd say
this one's definitely headed towards a
draw but we'll see if by June she can
you know work some magic here is if
anyone's gonna win I'd say you would
only be and the players who are gonna
work their magic are fighting for a lot
in this event we do have a very
lucrative prize fund let's take a look
at our prize fund for group a six
thousand dollars is the grand prize
going to our champion and in Group B not
too bad itself four thousand dollars we
will have a combined prize fund of 36
thousand dollars so that's really cool
for an event like this you know spring
chess classic really stepping it up for
the 2,500 2,600 level players seeing a
lot of new faces and names for the first
time okay take us to a game while we get
our first interview Nicholas theodoro
set up as we talk to him for the first
time in the spring at chess classic all
right well let's jump to the a section
and just see how the games are
progressing there because a lot of these
games in the a group are well underway
and we see some fascinating positions
here especially the one between Vasily
Yvan shook and Ray Robson so we have
Vasily with the white pieces here
against Ray and Roxy it has just been
played but but first of all we sort of
have to take stock of the position here
because if anyone wants to do a head
count you'll notice that white has the
two bishops but it looks like there was
a sacrifice on f4 that took place so
he's already given up the exchange and
I'll just go back a few moves to show
how that happened but Queen h4 he had to
play Brooke f4 and after takes takes
this kind of wacky position appeared on
the board and looks like again another
slow-moving game only a move 19 here for
[Music]
45 chicken ray Robson we saw Atari and a
cobia moved 13 which is again kind of
insane so seems like everyone is it's
sort of going slower than than usual
today
but someone wasn't going slower than
usual today and actually has this game
finished is Nicolas Theodor who's
joining us in the studio welcome thank
you so yeah Nicolas you you won your
game I was just saying how some games
were I Shawn moved like 13 they're still
playing and here we go we actually have
a decisive result in in the B section so
if you wouldn't mind take us through the
game especially just right back to the
starts abouts maybe some key moments and
where you think maybe went wrong for
your opponent yeah so my opponent played
this line in quite a few games so I had
prepared before and moved on
we were prepared up to move down yeah
and this is not to abnormal this Queen
exchange even though black can't castle
it's still pretty pretty standard so as
we get up to move ten you were talking
about this move here this before me
yeah it looks strange but I'm pretty
sure it's a novelty okay so I just look
at this one hour before I'm getting
maybe so he played 97 I guess I can ask
the the obvious question is what if he
takes I think it's actually the best
move and I have to play Knight d2 mhm
after which he has to play Bishop e6 and
now after before if I have I think more
than enough compensation for the right
so just playing for the initiative here
and this King starts to feel a little
uncomfortable maybe with the open C file
now yeah okay yeah so did he spend did
he spend quite some time on before I
think he spent about five minutes to
plate 97 but spend a lot of time after
b5 right like half an hour or so right
yeah b4 b5 and gets the whole idea of
this this supposes novelty that you
mentioned is just a rip open the Queen
side exactly yeah
just create some issues for this King on
c7 so you said he spent some time here
d5 he came up this with this move h6
which I mean it has some some obvious
obvious intentions but what did you
think of h6 I think reasonably move I
mean he obviously prevented me from
playing 95 and he he might also consider
blank f5 in some positions mm-hmm maybe
try to block the bishop I don't know
rook t1 you played and was there a point
where you felt like you really got a
serious advantage in this game I think
I'm not exactly sure about the
evaluation okay good me neither
rook t1 96
takes 92 and I guess when did you sort
of exit let's say preparation or you
still had some ideas I imagine the
preparation of Education right
and here a nice trick was if I play
Bishop III he has looked actually -
right we also cover d6
as well as working these so that's nice
should be too then
so after C 594 I mean take stakes 94
then you get to six square it starts to
look pretty good I don't think I have
any other options though right it's
pretty straightforward right
it's forcing you to play some some good
moves maybe takes and now he told me
after the game that he completely missed
Bishop c3 Bishop a5 idea right when he
played takes takes and look at the 8th
mm-hmm
because I guess this is actually really
annoying to ever challenge the cyllage
so did he his intention was to play
takes take after look at the 896 you
want to play other Knight a5 or 98
mm-hmm but after Bishop III he he
doesn't have any moves right okay so he
was intending let's say move like this
taking advantage of the pin but then
after this he's just in trouble right
yeah yeah
so probably his only option was to take
on it too instead of look at the eight
right here yeah did you play after which
I wasn't exactly sure what's going on
but I thought rook e1 Bishop h6 and snow
Knight d6 he might be able to play of
sheikhs
and now f4 looks reasonably yeah rugby
right and maybe even bishop I you wanna
just
try to take your next no because if I
play Bishop she 395 become my to become
annoying mm-hmm yeah you can get a check
but
so actually missing missing bishops III
to a five but causes business yeah that
was critical rook takes t1 but then
after rook T 896 probably I guess did he
notice at this point because now he had
to change his ideas and and he came up
with Bishop e2 but now I guess it's much
different than the previous line yeah
yeah yeah Rocky one
Bishop a6 you play Bishop c3 pretty
natural yeah the rook the Aiden
essentially we're we're almost just down
full full tempo from the last line we
looked at together yeah
so you took 95 and yeah did it seem just
pretty straightforward from from here or
or were there any it looked quite
straightforward but I and I also
considered Bishop a5 King be 7 and right
here you mean yeah you should check King
be 7 and Bishop h3 English seven for
example didn't take on e5 it also looks
really good for a while I thought Bishop
takes e5 a simpler right right bye-bye
you rights Bishop takes five takes
roughly five but with 96 and and and
this I think the position becomes just I
think that he did have one chance and
another if it's correct but Bishop CIA
right Knight b3 there could be five and
now he might attack Siwon he might be
able to play in the egg and after Knight
d4 93 it might be completely crazy but
that's an interesting 94 Knight c3 Shah
Rukh's III could be one ratio perform he
has Bishop h6 and the D the difference
is that if he's King cousin Bai I get to
play rook with a check
right so actually the the same line play
King the aegis doesn't work yeah
huh that's an interesting did he
obviously he didn't see it but did you
discuss it with him I told him again but
we couldn't find we just discussed it we
flee but we couldn't find anything for a
while right like immediate sure
so still better but maybe yeah yeah
maybe he could defend follow someone
amongst right some more work to do and I
see three is is fascinating
unfortunately then I guess for him he
played King v8 and then the whole line
doesn't work so 94 and now and I'd see
three as you mentioned there's gonna be
a rookie three in the end yeah so 94 and
you just resigned yeah yeah he's gonna
lose some material work a 596 and
obviously the night is tonight is
hanging so yeah that was a really
actually really quick game I guess for
us was the first first game done so
obviously it's a nice for you to get get
that win but you're also doing quite
well in in the group so far so off to a
good start in a tournament yeah that's
true about the team are you sure I can't
get too excited right right that's a
good attitude that's a good attitude
obviously Congrats on the win today
thanks for taking us through the game
and yeah that's Nicolas theodoro in
Group B looking to stay on top of the
tournament Thanks all right Wow and that
was a quick game to start us off here
for today's action in Group B also in in
Group B there are some pretty pretty
exciting games and ones that look like
could easily could easily finish with
some some nice attacks for example the
one between Sergei Arenberg playing
white here against korilla both sides
are launching a pretty devastating
attack on one another white with ideas
like rook g3 and the g7 pawn and in
black with a 30 minute time advantage
and this tender pawn on d3 which is just
sort of holding the whole Queen side
together you have to wonder positions
like this who is gonna crash through
first but there's actually quite a lot
of attacking games going on
and wouldn't be surprised to see some
more finishes decisive results in today
a game that really caught my eye during
that interview was Vasilyev on Chuck
versus Ray Robson they know that davon
chuck is maybe underperforming a little
bit I'm not really sure right if that's
proper to say but he looks to be in
command right here and there's a night
pin in the center of the board right now
in the current position right and there
we see Vasily von Schuch on your screen
there's been a few moves since we had
checked this scheme last so the rook was
on c8 and essentially just complete
paralysis here for for Ray's position is
you've got the bishop lined up to the
queen and it's really hard for black to
get developed here this isn't
necessarily that the blacks just up the
exchange this is like facility von
Schuch probably with a really good
sacrifice because what does black have
to do knight c6 rook takes AAA and
Knight takes d4 pinned in the center of
the board Knight takes eetu is the way
out of that so that brings a few moves
to mind like even something as as crazy
is like king each one becomes a thought
just to completely pin that night and
say that you don't have any way out if
we did something like king h1 then Queen
b6 comes to mind is a way to keep
defending that night but get out of the
pin I'm not sure if King h1 is is
completely necessary I mean we can play
this Bishop anywhere Bishop takes g4 as
well you got to think about all these
discovered checks though Knight f3 92
and then the Queen comes down and takes
the bishop on b2 but I think I'd take
the pawn you grab it on yeah I'm going
for it you'd grab it Bishop takes g4 and
and here at Queen takes f4 is not quite
a checkmate threat because actually
after Bishop takes here we cover all the
checking squares so it's nothing to
worry about after Bishop takes let's say
something like
ninety-two or night f3 the reason why
it's not not that scary is let's say
even pawn takes Queen takes here I
imagine with with a move like Bishop
Bishop e6 taking here pawn takes on e4
that that white should have the upper
hand but for example Bishop e6 here in
Bishop d7 is also something to consider
hitting this night saying that it's
pinned to the rook so something like
this may also yield a big advantage for
Yvonne sure because we see both players
on the move 21 in the game so far and 13
minutes 11 minutes apiece there's
probably going to be a time scramble
here but Yvonne choic seems to be
tactically in control is what it looks
like yeah looking an advantage for
Yvonne Chuck let's jump over to group b
Sorokin versus Mistah strange situation
here we have on the live board the C
pawn Sorokin z' C pawn down on the
seventh rank and the last move was rook
d8 Wow
try counting the pieces here does this
pay off for white well let's see how
that pawn even got there
so it looks like this came from a
grünfeld I recognize this position and
Sorokin here with the white pieces went
for this sort of enterprising idea after
Queen c4 he said okay let's go D takes
c6 so he gets a knight he loses a queen
he also gets a row but the the sort of
ace in the hole is that pawn on c6 going
all the way bishop f8 c7 Bishop e7
double the rooks king f7 and rook d8 on
the board Wow Wow
okay so let's have a look here rook d8
first of all if whites position is
pretty solid there are maybe some back
rank issues but the Queen is not in a
position to give to make that threat yet
Queenie for anything that guards the
rook we can just queen and after that
the material is in White's favor so if I
have to give up my rook for this pawn
that's pretty much it if I take though
which seems to be the big consideration
that's where we get the real imbalance
here is I don't think rook you know 37
is not anything I could take with the
rook or the pawn the rook looks trickier
because then I'm still threatening to
maybe get a queen together you Queenie
four right Queenie four and again this
pawn is down here but the question is
[Music]
questioning I guess I have to play maybe
a make an escape square I think I
probably have to make an escape square
or play the move Knight d2 but what
black wants to do next is he wants to
play Queen d7 rook c8 and then finally
take that pawn it seems like he he's
actually able to do that so let's say in
the worst case in all these
complications what we're likely to see
whether we see rook takes d8 or pawn
takes is we're likely to see you know
like a rug and two pieces against the
Queen let's say and if that were to
happen because black actually takes on a
two and we have this a pawn running it's
quite possible especially since that
night you know you see all those
business squares covered by the black
pawns it's hard to make any threats
against the King this could actually be
in in Black's favor if we're not careful
here is why that a pawn runs pretty
quickly and the bishop and I just aren't
very helpful yeah it what a heartbreaker
for Sorokin if that's the case because
it just looks so hopeful with that pawn
behind enemy lines I just want to do
something with it you know
well I think he can he can do better
than what we what I just said because I
think at the very very least you know it
feels like he can
maybe leave that pawn on c7 and maybe
have a rook go down to d8 which was the
other line we looked at and then at
least black has to work a little bit
harder to to get a queen against the the
pieces but the move that was just played
on the board is Queen a4 trying to deal
with the situation tactically is
Alexander Mista and we actually have
another move coming straight off the bat
that's rook one to d7 so after rook d7
one thing that does is it removes the
possibility of Bishop takes d8 now just
as a threat so if there's no Bishop d8 I
feel like we almost have to I mean now
I'm getting a little concerned because
rook takes his threat and if rook takes
right then just just takes and you can't
even take me back now this is this is
concerning to me so I'm not sure I mean
that I don't know I can't say for sure
but to me that that move looks really
strong by white pinning the bishop now
all those lines I was talking about
where maybe we want to take the rook try
to get that Queen against the three
pieces I don't even see those existing
anymore because the bishops pinned and
if we play like King here I'll just play
rook takes and I've got Queen next move
and if Queen takes and I make a queen
there is no back rank because that is
paying to the King so even these lines
don't seem to be working out here yeah
it's suddenly looks very very solid for
white yeah this no this move again I
don't know if there were other lines in
the last position but Queen a4 and rook
d7 looks like good sequence for white
because now the threat is just rook
takes and let's say Queen c6
what happens after Queen c6 that looks
like a move Queen c6 though there's
technically no threats in the position
he is not threatening anything with the
move Queen c6 because this is not a
threat and there's no other there's no
other moves really so white can actually
do whatever he wants
for example he may even be threatening
something as crazy as like ninety-five
forking the King and Queen and if pawn
takes maybe Bishop g5 all of a sudden I
mean I just see a ton of lines which
just work for white based on Queen a4
and rook d7 so I wouldn't be surprised
here Ben if if Sorokin might actually
get his first point of the tournament
and it'd be a win at that against
Grandmaster Mistah indeed alright guys
if you want to keep up to the action
keep up to date with the action remember
us chess champs dot-com is your stop for
all of this stuff having to do with
spring chess classic the standings the
games live the ones we're not talking
about you can see them at any time
Sergey Arenberg versus Christian korilla
in Group B when we last had it I think
more moves played right queen g6 on the
board for Arenberg yep this this was
actually the same position and korilla
is still thinking from the last time I
brought it up right from the start well
this started as a Sicilian but it was
one of those positions actually quite
similar been to the VAR game that I was
mentioning the idea of Knight takes on
d3 and how white sometimes wants to take
with a pawn this is another example of
where that exchange has actually
happened and what it's done is this
created a fun position maybe not for
them but for spectators at the very
least because no one likes to be sort of
living on the edge like this some people
do but it's risky it's risky you never
know whose attacks can crash through
first and what we see here is gorilla
with a 20-minute time advantage or more
and Sergei Arenberg sitting at just one
minute moved 27 so they have 13 moves to
play until that time control hits and he
really feels more comfortable with with
the extra time but it's white trying to
crash
here on the kingside and black with
maybe some sacrificial ideas also
pressuring that d3 pawn trying to crash
through on the queenside and let me tell
you this looks like a very tense
position so it looks like blacks gonna
crash through a lot faster wouldn't you
think well he's thinking right now and
he's got upon this just just completely
hanging so he could take this but then
first of all there's this pawn hanging
there's also rook g3 to think about and
I think rook g3 is is really what he's
focusing on here because rook g3 if I
just keep take take taking Bishop g7 and
I have to really be concerned about
getting meted myself so the problem I
think that the Kirill is facing here is
that he needs to put some element of
defense into his next couple of moves
which you know you never liked to do you
wish you could just attack attack attack
but it looks like rook g3 with this
threat it's quite serious serious enough
that I think he has to deal with it
defensive Bishop f6 doesn't hold up
anything so Bishop f6 the issue right
now is that the knight on c5 would just
be hanging so you would actually have to
throw in 93 and then rook g3 and then 96
but if we did that Bishop f6 now again I
could take it and if you take you're
getting mated and you can't take that
way so it's that's probably the type of
things that he's thinking about here
this is frustrating you want those
defensive moves to work but at the same
time he wants to maintain his attack so
I think what he's facing here is this
rook g3 move and Bishop takes g7 Bishop
f8 does cover things so for example like
this
Bishop f8 seems to hold things together
a little bit but I mean rook here I mean
these are some scary lines to be
calculating with Queen h6 Bishop takes
Queen takes c6 and it's just this really
puts the to human calculation to the
test when you're you're going move by
move who crashes through first cuz it
all has to come with with tempo and make
sure that you're not getting needed
before you deliver made yourself
Arenberg really down on time here you
can see 20 to 1 on the clock
yep no he is suffering especially in a
position like this Bend which is so
tactical and requires really so much
calculation you can bet that in this
position while it scurrilous turn to
think the heat is just like racking his
brains trying to think as well because
he as soon as it's his turn
he's almost got to move instantly for
the next 13 moves I want to look at
baarish bullets versus Stein crimson
also in Group B they're in an endgame
with rooks and a minor on each side
right and look so we got pawns on the
outside but they're blocking each other
right so well I have to say initially
that this looks this looks a little
better for four bars bullets here
he's got the bishop against the knight
most importantly he's got this pawn on
f3 which gives him an escape square but
it also really kills this this Knight at
where it can go aggressively black on
the other hand has to always be
concerned about back rank issues let's
not forget that there is a pawn hanging
on f5 here and on top of everything you
know if I can establish this bishop on
this diagonal then I could easily defend
my pawn maybe while also contributing to
the attack so I think definitely
slightly better for for white in this
position whose turn is as white to move
so rook takes before was the last move
but the rooks I really like in the
center here and I think that the back
rank threats combined with the fact that
this pawn and this pawn look a little
bit loose to me and this Knight is
dominated by the pond I think white has
a noticeable advantage here I think
white is it noticeable event he's just
play to move actually since we've been
on the board he went ruk to b5 so the
idea being takes takes and we're hitting
this pawn so okay maybe a3 will be
played but this is what I'm talking
about where the bishop can establish
itself on this diagonal and and
hopefully get comfortable there while
the rook maybe goes to a6
takes the pawn d3 take the pawn
this looks like white is maybe picking
up upon here and looking good in the
endgame you're giving bearish bullets
the advantage here do you think that
black is going to take him up on a
Brooke trade well that's an important
question first of all because the only
thing about rook p5 is that it nearly
forces it rook c4 is not possible
neither
I mean rook age for Brooke f4 seemed a
little bit insane obviously there's g3
and both of those lines rook check can
be played but again leaving the last
rank just exposes you further -
checkmate ideas so I'm not sure that
he's going to be too interested in doing
this and otherwise yeah you're pretty
much forced to take me so I think that
he's kind of forced to play rook takes
b5 Bishop takes p5 and and after this
you know with you're a pawn hanging
maybe you don't play a three but if you
don't you've got to play probably Brooke
a a okay a rook check would be another
move to consider King f2 rook check
right to take this but I think this is
where we start to realize those back
rank issues right here here and it's
just game over bye-bye either checkmate
or I'm gonna win all your material so
that's why there's there's no way to
solve the issue tactically and and I do
think bars bullets has has advantage
here in this game even though it's
almost symmetrical
night against bishop but I think the
bishop really can't dominate the night
and especially with the back rank issues
I think Stein Grimson still has a lot to
prove if he wants to draw in this game
very well yeah I didn't notice that all
that entire rink was cut off yeah the
whole reason to avoid a trade there
can't go here here here and then of
course these last two squares f4 and h4
there's always g3 to to hit the rook so
kind of annoying but I think his hand is
forced into this exchange one way or
another and that should favor white here
as he gets rid of a rook and weakens the
a pawn for
future one game that we should glance at
in group a is our star from yesterday
Grandmaster Denis Nick taking on the
2004 feed a world champion wisdom chasm
Jean off right and what do we have in
this game nish Nick seems to be a fan of
double pawns Ben that's all I can say
about this one so far
niche Nick is got to see he's got two
sets of double isolated pawns here on
the F and B files so just everything is
weak okay that's what it looks like I
mean if we go back a little bit he
actually weakened chasm jenoff spawns
and funny enough chasm Janov instead of
playing pawn takes on d5 in this
position he was like okay I don't want
the double isolated F pawns so I'm gonna
throw this up the board make sure you
have them and then I'm gonna take so
people are trying to avoid the double
isolated pawns which makes a lot of
sense here queen d3 was the last move
and here we are on the board chasm Jan
of ticking down under four minutes here
they've got thirteen moves to make ninja
Nick with plenty of time but it's
actually these ponds which are quite
solid in my opinion for white this B
pond does prevent the a pond from moving
so basically these pawns are just fixed
for the moment Brook a1 in the future
for example just targets the a pond it
can't move it's sort of a sitting duck
also this pawn on d5 as we can see is
completely under attack here and if you
play the move d4 which looks entirely
logical I have to wonder about this move
because first of all we are not really
threatening to take because the rook is
hanging here tonight f5 is a very
natural move to hit the Queen and the
pawn
he has played d4 and and of course he
should because there's no way to defend
the pawn in this position from Knight
tasty five so he's gonna push it and
he's gonna say okay you know let's say
something like this happens of course
he's gonna respond to ship g7 and it's
actually white who's maybe in trouble
here with the
the rook but there might be a way a way
out of this for example like I don't
know Queen Queen III or Queen e2 one
line which is just not working it's this
of course we don't even have to take
that rook t4 is just suicide because of
Queen here and checkmate so there are
few ways to tactically defend but I
don't think it's gonna be in White's
interest to ever play Knight a5 and take
that pawn this just doesn't make a lot
of sense to put your knight right in the
line of fire so I think Nick here is
gonna look to try to play the night
against the bishop position but I don't
think that the chasm Janov is is in too
much trouble in this position as long as
he establishes sort of bishop on g7
Queen on f6 I think I think he can hold
this position actually as the pawns are
technically technically equal here and I
want to jump back to Group B because we
have a happening or we think we're about
to have a happening Sorokin versus
Mistah and here that Mesa is shaking his
head and it does not like what he sees
remember that pawn behind enemy lines oh
I didn't like what I saw you there so I
I understand the head shake what what
did he play rook e7 you played Queen e4
h 4 yeah and this is what I was saying
as soon as you take away the back rank
mate there's no threats for black I mean
you're just a sitting duck King e6 rook
b8 which is a very cute move because
you're just sort of clearing the way
it's like Usher
you're just you got teased to muscular
rooks on either side just keeping
everyone away from the very petite
ariana grande there who's about to
promote and what are you gonna do
rook b8 if you take okay I take back new
Queen if you take my rook now I've got
c8 protected by the roof so the rook on
a8 is essentially a non participant in
this game and it's a nice move probably
one that means two overlooked but I
can't say that it's one that you know if
you didn't have that move that black was
fine or anything like that so it's a
nice move but I think missed it was
probably lost in in any case
yeah Grande's looking pretty good right
here and we saw that mister just moved
with seconds left on the clock inherent
he is shaking hands and Sorokin Alexei
Sorokin the FM in Group B is on the
board he's on the board Bishop d6 was
played and now after rook takes d6 it's
just game over and he resigned here
because of course King takes and there's
just another Queen appearing on the
board so actually that that Queen
sacrifice completely worked in the end
now I don't know but you know on its way
whether it was completely sound but
that's just you know that's just like
the human instinct he he saw that that
pawn gets up to c7 and be tough to
handle and he took his chance and well
obviously it paid off in the end but
mister felt the pressure of that pawn
always being one square away from
Queenie and it was enough to get Sorokin
on the board as you said so a nice first
win and confidence boost for him yeah I
think there was a fun little combination
we saw there at the end I think there's
one game we haven't taken a look at yet
Benjamin Bach versus Geoffrey Zhang in
Group A right let's take a glance now we
know that Benjamin Bach of the
Netherlands he won his game I believe
yesterday and Geoffrey Zhang a US Junior
Championship competitor champion the
world champion and junior chess let's
see what's going on here only a minute
left for Bach yeah less than a minute
there and he's really feeling it from
Jeffrey Zhang but he's just played as we
see here this this is what the issue is
coming from this position
Zhang has this rook on c3 which is so
annoying if I just put this rook or
rather put this pawn on d6 and say that
your work has to go back that it can't
establish itself so deep in my position
maybe like seriously better for white
much better position but that rook on c3
is so annoying that we almost overlooked
the black is sitting there with an
isolated pawn because that rook on c3
hits the pawn on b3 I never want to take
it because you take back and suddenly
that C pawn is very dangerous but he
unleashed a combination a few moves ago
Bishop d6 Queen F
and Bishop takes on each - why can't the
King just not take the bishop on h2 so
King h1 played by Bach in view of this
idea which we take this rook on c1 as a
result of Queen c7 checks so not a very
difficult tactic but when you're down to
a minute and you're feeling that
pressure I mean this is the explanation
for why we see the blender coming in
there but now I think it's no surprise
that Jong is completely winning as a
result of this tactic so King h1 had to
be played I mean any time the guy can
just sort of like open your door and
grab the cookie jar and leave punch in
that's that's pretty bad news
so Bishop back to e5 he's threatening to
take here then the b3 pawn hangs Knight
to b5 was played the question for me is
whether the rook takes b3 can be played
because of rook takes b3 can be played
then black is just completely winning
here it looks like it can for the most
part rook takes d5 then just a queen
move we're actually threatening Queen h6
here as well
getting down there and we've got this
past beep on so rook takes b3 looks like
a big move here also maybe just rook
takes rook takes and just play a pawn up
here but he's gonna calculate here he's
got time to do so and it's Bach with a
minute he's blundered upon and basically
he's flailing at this point I expect him
to lose this game another game that's
about to end in Group E is Kai Donovan
by ginchy tadhana was on the verge of
resigning and I also understand we do
have a Lexus or Oken about to come in
for an interview so what's glance at
this while while we get him set up right
and wow this is just by ginchy a top
group B who's really making an
impression so far in the tournament is
as it looks like he's grinding out a win
from what seemed to be a rather harmless
endgame now there was definitely a space
advantage for black definitely the the
pieces were were quite impressive for
black I mean almost everything was
better than the counterpart for white
the King was better placed the the
knight was better but it didn't feel
like that was enough to
actually grind out a win here but he's
proving he's proving me wrong look at
this
e5 was the last move played by white and
it's now black to play and I have to
feel like as long as we move the King
just don't play the move g3 because what
White's gonna do is he's he's going to
play Nike - he's gonna capture that pawn
so for example here right there and he
can actually take this and I imagine
with the pawn pushing up the board and
the King coming in he'll actually be
able to save this but instead he's
actually played the move King III which
seems logical and the real issue here is
something like g3 is gonna happen and
then maybe H 3 H 2 H 1 so by June she
looks like he's he's maybe on the verge
of just completely winning here against
Kadena so a bit of an end game collapse
or maybe that position was actually a
lot more difficult than then I thought
because he's actually gonna pull out a
win in this game but while he does that
we're actually going to jump into an
interview with Alexis orc and from
Russia thank you very much for joining
the broadcast and we just took a look at
a very exciting game that you just
played against Alexander Mista he came
away with a victory and in doing so he
also sacrifice your queen in a pretty
fun way so we'd love it if you'd maybe
take us through some key variations
especially want to know but that Queen
sac because that looked that looked like
a lot of fun so what did you think about
the opening from from you I didn't know
the move b6 and I spend a lot of time
about 40 minutes for calculation some
variations right
and then I find this is 65 so this was
pretty this is all pretty standard right
yeah yeah yeah and were you pretty much
in in your preparation for the most part
here my open and he didn't play okay
yeah so everyone is free for all they
should be 5 f6 and we've seen this this
line before definitely and then I see 6
yeah it's mine line this one here yeah
yes
Knight d7 and take the bishop
currency free bishop would be free and
Quincy man Quincy free right yeah yeah
something like this yeah so actually I
mean there's there's even main lines
were the Queen gets sacrificed so it's
not a not a new idea but it certainly
seemed like he did it in a unique way
when it happened in the game
b6 was played and yet you said you spent
quite some time after this right just
checking everything yeah yeah for sure
and after Bishop a6 I mean did you did
you always have the intention to sort of
follow up with with maybe a dc-6 move at
some point did you expect him to play
the way that he did yes
takes work everyone yeah and in this
position my opponent also spent a lot of
time I think that he had interesting
move or night very five like yeah and I
think work is fine doing fine
yeah maybe I should play c4 Knight Queen
to maybe take maybe take off a four and
some interesting position but I think
block is fine in all variations right
yeah so my opinion to cram I can choose
a different variant sure do you think
maybe that was better like how did you
evaluate maybe this this position here i
I think that Bishop afraid and a son is
very strong if I didn't calculate it sir
bishop or take take later
and after rook g8 I don't understand why
and my opening just so he can just take
everything yes the line that I was
expecting I don't know I think it's
about equal position what might be even
black have some chances were you
planning to take with the partner or
porn because if I take the rucas and
queen for a queen a four or queen before
me for yeah right and okay no basically
it should be the same type of thing but
worst version for you maybe you have to
yeah I spent some time in the Queen see
six is coming so yeah that's true but
yeah I also simply thought that this
position I mean I don't know how you
evaluated it but maybe seems like also
could be scary for for what yeah yeah I
I think that it's about trickle because
I always have some check yeah you can
put the rook and maybe okay some counter
play on yeah always some but of course
black position fine
yeah yeah so maybe just some some yeah
an oversight or over estimation and
Korean ninety four big mistake it should
just be a big blunder and this movies
yeah wait might be
I don't know why right yeah yeah well I
was wondering maybe what might be might
be a queen c6 and then I play Knight a5
like b5 yeah yeah no this is so maybe he
was intending this and they overlooked
95 it's possible
oh maybe if like right it's another
strong move because yeah then it's just
impossible to stop me because yeah it's
possible maybe he was considering well
if he ever takes and I always have the
the c8 square covered but rook b8 is a
nice nice touch too to finish off and
and yeah basically it's just just
winning at this point so rook b8 Bishop
d6 and of course he was just down two
seconds so no no difficulty finishing
off with rook takes and obviously your
Queen next move so yeah we wasn't sure
but let's say pawn takes on c6 whether
it was good all the way or bad all the
way but it seemed like a really
interesting game and and maybe just he
should have played Bishop takes d8 and
we would have seen three pieces against
the Queen it would have been also an
interesting endgame yeah but okay you
came away with the win it's also your
first point in tournaments so I mean
Congrats it's really good to get on the
board with a nice game here I wanted to
ask you about I mean your rating your FM
sitting with a big rating you're you're
obviously yeah I have two grandparents
so I wanna just keep yeah yeah yeah yeah
those unnecessary steps when okay you're
already playing at the level so okay
obviously this is a good tournament to
chance to do that and it's nice to get a
win here so one step closer but so
thanks for taking us through the game
and good luck in the rest of your games
yeah thanks alright so we're gonna jump
back into the games guys but that was
Alexi Sorokin who took us through his
nice win there and let's see who is
still in progress here and we have that
really exciting game from earlier that
we were taking a look at between Sergei
Ehrenberg and Christian Corolla and
actually korilla has gotten all the way
down to two minutes and Arenberg has
been playing on one minute this whole
time so both players are are now
basically a surviving on the increment
and this was one of my favourite games
to look at earlier because both sides
were just launching absolutely
everything in the position going for the
attack Knight takes e4 was played by
korilla this is jumping back a few moves
ago when we were looking at it
rook g1 and of course it looked like it
would just be a pileup on the G file
here and after takes Queen back to b5
this is the current position there's
been one more move Knight to c1 so I
mean these are the positions that the
attacking player lives for it doesn't
even matter if you're white or black
here right you know that the position is
gonna be completely messy I have to say
that it strikes me that as long as
there's nothing happening here which
there isn't at the moment black should
be winning he's got the two bishops he's
got control of this diagonal and the
White King is was almost like one check
away from basically checkmate as he's
boxed in here completely so rook here
and you know that's that's a threat for
white but that's a few moves away here
and rook to d8 has been played and this
is what I mean we're broke d8 you hit
that bishop and the problem is there's
just no time for this black starts to
get his pieces in with tempo and
exposing that you know all these pieces
there one move away from the big threat
on g7 but right now they're not
anything I mean and you can't even
really defend the bishop without right
no you can't out pulling stuff off the G
file exactly so he played Bishop e5 and
I mean in this position we already have
to think about ideas like how this rook
gets in into the position both players
down and now actually korilla is lower
on time than Ehrenberg which is actually
crazy I mean if you remember he actually
had 30 minutes to 1 minute right earlier
so he tanked all his time not in a bad
way I mean he spent it wisely and I
think they still got this position under
control but who knows what the the time
is gonna do is 7 more moves need to be
played and I believe that he really just
moved there he did I'm not sure what he
did know he played Bishop to b7 Bishop
b7 hitting upon the e4 and essentially
getting ready for probably some
sacrificial stuff here got a result in
Group A Benjamin Bach and Geoffrey Zhang
Zhang has one with the black pieces the
pawn storm we got to pass pawns on the a
and B files too much for Benjamin box so
maybe we will be able to talk to Jeffrey
here in just a moment congratulations to
Geoffrey Zhang a former Classic champion
here at at the st. Louis chess club and
also world junior champion 2016
absolutely
ya know that that game was the one where
it just all looked bad for for Benjamin
that tactic on H 2 blundering the pond
and then of course from from there you
just March the pawns up the board so
that's a nice game for Geoffrey I see we
also have alienation ik Andrew stem
chasm Jean oh if they had a draw in
their game that was the position that I
was saying looked quite equal early on
so that's no surprise to me there as
they were getting low on time and it was
the bishop against Knight position so
that one's also a draw and that means
Illya continues to to sort of do well in
the the a group right in the B group hi
Donald still has not resigned and this
is something before the interview with
Sorokin we
thought we were gonna see Gregory katana
imminently just resigned but he's still
playing on yeah yeah and I think I think
you always play these positions on
because it's not something that you ever
study in a book it's just you've got a
pawn in a knight
hey I mean that's the people get forked
all the time so these are tricky pieces
still he's gonna play it on absolutely
bhaijan cheesie's no doubt completely
winning but he's gonna have to find out
exactly how to do that and I've even
experienced myself some of these tricky
end games where the pawn gets so far
down the board and if it was just a
queen against that pawn of course
there's the normal technique about how
to triangulate how to win but then when
you add a knight to that situation just
like ruins your whole coordination and
and you start to maybe get confused so
he's definitely gonna play this on but
with correct play and of course they've
hit in 40 lots of time for by ginchy to
find this he should be all right we
understand that the superstar from
Dallas metro area
Jeffrey Zhong will be in for an
interview shortly so fantastic leave you
and see you in just a moment absolutely
yeah no we got lots of games here to
keep us occupied one of the ones I want
to take a look at is one that we haven't
jumped to yet which is Eric Hanson's
game so what is he doing in his position
against long lien it seems to me like
while the position might be rather equal
I want to jump back a few moves here
both players have hit time control but
it seems to me like Eric's position
would be slightly preferred he's got the
repetition on the board if he wants it
here but he's also hitting them 40 so he
can sort of decide here how how he wants
to how he wants to play he can take this
draw looks like the last couple moves
have been a repetition but alternatively
he can choose to play on here and he's
got the time to to think about it and
decide what what exactly he wants to do
but Hansen's position seems to seems to
have improved we haven't jumped to this
game really
today so far but it looks like it's okay
maybe it would be equal but I think
Ericsson on the slightly better side of
things with the with the current pawn
structure but in the meantime we're
gonna be jumping to an interview with
Grand Master Geoffrey Zhang who is
joining us here in the broadcast welcome
Jeffrey thank you and we just saw you
take care of your game against Benjamin
Bloch and it actually seems I mean he
missed a tactic near the end but hoping
you could take us through the game from
the start and maybe some of the key
moments yeah definitely I I believe that
he played more or less quite well of for
a long time mm-hmm because okay I
thought I had a very reasonable position
of the opening but it turned out there
was some slight pressure and he kind of
kept pressing so yeah it's a go ahead
so yeah Queens gambit accepted right
and this b3 line is he played c5 b3 it's
becoming quite fashionable so it's very
slowly try yeah and this was all I I
checked before did you expect b3 from
from Benjamin specifically or but yeah
it's everyone's been playing is
surrounding me yeah something to be
up-to-date with so a 4v4 9bd - yeah all
of this I had so after I'm Brooke c1
castles now you see four takes I I mean
looked at night takes yeah Bishop takes
also is a move mm-hmm but okay all I can
remember was 95 should be correct but
that was about it
makes sense and perhaps 95 was
over-ambitious because maybe I can just
swap the Knights I mean Knight takes e5
I assume you take with Knight
and something like what see a possibly
should be very close to equal if not
equal already bright but I decided to
try 95 maybe more interesting was that
in I hope to be ambitious or just to
keep the pieces on them yeah just to
keep the pieces on RAM and yeah 95
he played Bishop f3 so yeah already he
hidden the night so it started to get a
bit uncomfortable okay Brooke see it
seemed logical and now 93 was very
strong because originally I'd planned
Knight c3 right now yeah and the idea is
that Bishop c3 Bishop f3 Queen f3 Knight
b3 and it looks like all of whites
pieces are hanging all right them
actually yeah actually the tactics
should work for me right
but unfortunately has a very nice trap I
think so instead of Bishop takes c3 he
can take the other night with Knight
takes e5 and okay if I grab the Queen he
goes Knight b7 and it's of an
overwhelming position I think yeah three
piece way too many so that was a huge
issue right so instead of Knight c3
added to settle for a 5 yep this is the
game a 5 yeah takes takes Knight a for
probably a decent approach mm-hmm and I
it was a confusing position because I
think it was very hard for me to
untangle and strategically the a5 pawn
will always be a weakness so it it
seemed maybe it's not terrible for black
but it's seems very quite unpleasant
mm-hmm yeah because you're gonna be
getting this this isolated pawn type of
position but you're almost saved by by
the idea that you know you can sort of
plan you look there later on would ya I
played Bishop e7 but I missed his next
move Queen d4 is very strong and his
idea is first Queen a7 to just simple
double tech and it's hard for me to
defend or Knight h5 going on
other side is also very dangerous right
so I thought okay it's I've simplified
so I took takes Bishop takes f3 I think
it's just a very unpleasant position
right we have three yeah I saw the
engine offered this by me it's very it's
it's hard to play I mean the night is
just so strong here and because ok I at
least read Bishop d5 to at least try to
kick the night yeah cuz then if you take
the night against the bishop I mean at
least the Knights not hitting your pawn
that's right exactly but the problem now
maybe you could have moved the other
rope to d1 and the point is let's say I
feel like in the game rook c5 mm-hmm now
he can play E 4 and Bishop g5 no longer
skewers of the rook right so now that
off so actually my plan was instead of
rook c5 I wanted to do something
interesting so I wanted to go Bishop g5
right away see right here again yeah
and ok he should probably play queen g4
g3 I'm not sure and then my plan was
actually or I thought about this is
probably not enough but I wanted to try
Bishop f6 let's say e 4 and I wanted to
try to sack the Queen so the right ship
takes c4 takes home d8 probably rook F
takes BC for b3 and I'm sure it's not
enough but maybe it was a try I don't
know it's interesting and just so strong
that pawn getting 2 to b2 and then
saying that maybe a few these pieces are
offside or yeah yeah it's probably over
up to this right because but if not for
this I I wasn't sure how to defend
against him if you didn't go through
that line yeah right I guess you'd have
you'd have a tough choice had he had he
done this in the game because it's just
definitely I mean I probably wouldn't
have done for this right so but he went
with the other rook
f2d one here rook c5 and now I wasn't
expecting cakes I thought he would play
Age 3 maybe because I wasn't sure
exactly what my threat is mm-hmm
and now I think I was going Bishop to g5
because now this is interesting
so the point being of queen g4 Queen c7
looks strong and I think right it's
working out Queen g5 just about three
and otherwise and on the C file he's a
bit annoying yep so he should probably
stay on this diagonal to stop Queen c7
right and it's another reason I guess
why though the rook on c1 is exactly
just lines like this let's see make a
queen g3 uh-huh
so I would keep chasing him for speech
for okay obviously if he goes back and
draws good but you can try queen h2 here
but now I think Quincy it could be
interesting yeah yeah same idea Knight
b6 but with clean h2 there should be
something like many rooks c1 this queen
SEC looks more promising and I see it
rook F c8 and yeah this looks much much
looks maybe more than promising yep
so yeah maybe in this case you would
have to kind of take a draw because
Queen a for a queen g3 yeah it's
difficult how to avoid race maybe back
and forth but these are all details from
from the rookie yes one which is a quick
Creek I think you ever see one may have
been just much better
so he took takes 95 rook c3 I should try
yep and I think he played correct he
should burn night to d4 because if he
grabs this pawn in a flood it's a bit
too much anything rook aid should track
the night immediately right so yeah 94
and now I said a little bit of a trap
but okay I wasn't expecting him to fall
for a play Bishop d6 was it also maybe
product of time pressures it was
definitely a was really getting low on
time around this point right yeah but
anyway I still expect him to play Queen
h4
right yeah and I was going to try f5
maybe again he was a long time so maybe
this line of four could be so I don't
your face yeah yeah because it's it's
always an annoying position where you
don't want to take but you're also tied
down to the feeling that rope there so
okay the Queen's offside as well and
it's it's not as comfortable as those
positions were the Knights on c-44 yeah
so yeah instead he Queen f3 was maybe
not losing move I mean not getting worse
because there was a line fish fish - eh
- it was hard for him to calculate with
only two minutes now so Queen g3 rook c1
rook c1 Queen C one night of five okay
if Queen like see a three for example
there's night h6 f7 so this is a draw
right so I have to try um I try g6 I
think mm-hmm I'm almost sure there
should be some draw but yeah feels like
it's close but not quite actually not so
yes for example let's make some move
Knight h6 because after nature okay
first if I can also play King h8
actually does queen - six King g7 but
yeah this Queen Eastern I guess also
should be drawn
I have to defend Quincy and nine of them
yeah at the very least yep
so he should I mean I should try after
night age 16 g7 oh yes mm-hmm
but okay now just a night of five back
so I mean yeah I guess this was right
yeah but Bishop h2 sometimes with the
times look I'm sure he missed the idea
probably and no I feeling he was
calculating this but he wasn't sure
right and yeah I guess it feels like
something you almost go for I guess if
you're otherwise he just take the pawn
and come back but yeah I guess when the
time is so maybe thought that he could
still hold I mean no hearing without the
h-bomb right right so also you should
have at least you should have gone to f1
probably because King on f1 looks better
mm-hm I'm just closer to the center and
no h-file nonsense
yeah cuz there was a few sort of like
Queen that coming to age six ideas yeah
change one Bishop e5 now wait so
probably again 92 I think was more
precise so tonight on b5 doesn't block
the fifth ring so he can take on 85
right something like this if you take on
b3 me
yeah like Rick near Queen d5 suddenly
it's a very different story with a five
right without the night there yep so
yeah 92 I would have had to take on c1
it's still upon up but good good
Georgians
mmm-hmm ya know he'll he'll play like
this but okay it's much better than that
game for sure it's not dealing with this
move
yes so 95 I think Queenie six was a
strong move mm-hm
just forcing him to open that file if he
wants the ending and it's hard to avoid
it because early a tried teens you won
but after rugby - it's it's very hard to
avoid because yeah it's hard to find
another move for him mm-hm I might want
to suddenly play Queen f6 for example
and yeah I mean if he doesn't trade the
Queen's maybe you actually keep them on
the board yeah and that King on each one
from earlier means after two scores a
little tender so right but now the
problem was with this template so like
26:56 ideally he would play rook c5 I
think actually rooks if I was probably
the best tries to just rook c5 right
because he somehow needs to I mean in
the game he just had no counter play at
all but somehow he has to figure out a
way right it actually seemed really
really smooth at some point I think so
the way that that it got converted I
mean f4 because okay actually the point
was if rook c5 I think I have to go
Bishop v8 which is much worse Square to
keep that file open for the rook right
because I mean if you can if you can
choose where were you yeah then we're
square right that's a good point yeah so
but again it's it's he's faced with this
tough job of like having to find all
these accurate kind of moves with such
low low time and I guess maybe this was
the last the last straw sort of because
once once you get review - and and rook
a4 imeem these speak for themselves and
the bishop kind of covers all the all
the threats around the King so it seemed
like this was just a nice nice finish as
well day one but again it's hard to for
him to cover cover everything so yeah
actually you managed to to come away
with a nice game it looked like it
pretty complicated
it'll game but so tactics worked in your
favor and maybe that critical move was
maybe Brooke f2d why not exactly yeah
obviously it was very fortunate because
I mean I was on the ropes for almost the
entire game so yeah I guess I think time
time was the main factor right the
turnaround right well I mean it's part
of the game so yeah Congrats on on the
win and obviously good luck in in the
rest of your games thanks for taking the
time thank you thanks alright that was
Grandmaster Jeffrey Zhang with win
against Benjamin Bach in very convincing
fashion there with some tactics and some
unfortunate time pressure for the
Grandmaster from the Netherlands and the
games here continue to I mean in Group A
there's actually still a few games
ongoing we've had two draws in Jeffrey
the first person to win in Group A but
orient re and version of Cobian still
going in their game in a very close Rock
end game as well as Eric Hansen declined
I believe unless he's still thinking
about it declined a three time
repetition against laQuan unless he's
unless he's still able to take it and
maybe he's just pondering that so what
do we have in Hansen's game I think it
was one - yeah it was one - and he
actually declined threefold repetition
to play the move Queen f3 but I think
he's more or less got this this draw on
hand with Queen 88 if he wants it but
he's sort of spending all his time
knowing that he's got that draw on hand
and trying to see like can he play for
more event one of the games that I was
looking for or looking at in Group B it
was Ehrenburg and gorilla the one right
the they attack insane attack right I
gotta be honest I just saw that meter
swing in White's favor big time but
I haven't seen why yet well Black has
just played Bishop to c5 taking a
protector off the Jeep on is that fatal
for gorilla so my position looks
absolutely different than yours let me
reload here maybe you mean vicious off
Bishop c5 was played but that was before
time control so the Bishop c5 move as we
see probably in resignation there from
Gregory Caetano
as Biden she does in fact you know take
care of things properly with the Queen
against the knight and the pond there
and again establishes himself as the
front-runner in in Group B he beat Skye
down off who kind of himself came off a
nice game yesterday so by June she just
sort of takes out a guy who was maybe
maybe looking for a second win in a row
yes and indeed that my position I
proposed earlier was outdated
well congratulations yes to by ginchy
but the front-runner he was expected to
win and he's playing up to those
expectations so far he is absolutely now
to talk about the position that you were
mentioning although position maybe has
developed a little bit the players have
hit time controls so Ehrenburg is Erin
Burke can finally breathe a little bit I
mean the guy has been playing on
increment for practically 20 moves here
with a single minute on the clock
finally he hits time control so he has a
bit more time to think he's got this
queen bee to check me an idea to always
be aware of but what was the last move
played it was rookie a check rook f8 and
[Music]
rookie 7 is played threatening mate and
the bishop I'm wondering if Rick f7 is
going to be the response or not
as rookies seven are there tricks here I
don't think so
that's Amit you couldn't move the rook I
guess rook d2 doesn't cover the Queen
here but okay there's all sorts of all
sorts of tactics in the position to look
out for so not actually sure what's
going on here
rook f8 was just played by korilla and
this game has probably I mean I'm sure
the evaluation has shifted up and down
blacks wedding white to enhance for the
last 10 has been pretty active talking
about it as well yeah I don't envy the
the guys who actually have to go and
calculate these variations because I can
just blender a rock or something butts
on the analysis for it but you know
these guys have had a game at stake here
yeah I don't be interesting to see who
actually who comes out in this one
because it's just a topsy-turvy kind of
affair baarish pullets versus stein
grooms in anything different in here
right this one is still still underway
here
Andriy bars poets I think this is the
type of position that I envisioned where
you sort of black can play passively get
that rook over there and he has to to
defend the a pawn otherwise it's just
it's just a goner to the white rook
you've still got that pawn controlling
where this black knight can go but at
the end of the day Stein Grimson is not
down material so you really can't you
can't come to too many conclusions about
how you know why he's totally winning
when blacks not even down material know
why it's better for sure and he's gonna
be pressing here as blacksburg is tied
down but I don't actually see I don't
actually see a way that the white can
break through I mean if you move the
knight there's Bishop f7 okay we can
move the knight back III don't see I
think he's passed the worst of it it
seems like earlier he had to worry about
maybe getting his King out and stuff
like that but now I think
he sort of survived that and I imagine
that this is probably gonna be a draw
but make no mistake white is slightly
better here and I expect baarish bullets
to to push push for a win we still have
a few games going on and before we end
the show I'd like like to glance one
more time at Eric Hanson versus Liam Lee
yeah it is intriguing that Eric turned
down the draw repetition and I want to
see if this pays off for him right now
again the position was sort of
developing like this and this was the
threefold it was night e8 Queen a eight
laid back Queen back neck back going
back and here at clean e4 would have
been the third time so he played Queen
f3 and lik long Liam responded with the
same move 98 so again it just seems like
he's got this Queen eight move if he
wants to and again that would be the
third time for that position so he's
sort of got this draw on hand even
though he changed his his mood so he
seems to have it whenever he wants now
why is he playing on because he's the
one who has the outside pass pawn
potential here so I think he's trying to
decide as the clock really takes down
here Ben is do you go for the draw or
not now here's that terrible thing in
chasis you spend half your clock
deciding whether to take the draw you're
almost making up the decision for
yourself because now you almost have to
take it otherwise playing on maybe you
miscalculate something you miss evaluate
something all of a sudden you're you're
got half the time of your opponent and
maybe you even are in trouble in some
lines where where you maybe miss
something so this is this is always that
scary moment for a chess player when
you've got that drawn hand and you're
like well it's right in front of me but
let me just think see if I have anything
else you spend so much time thinking you
just basically got to take the draw at
that point so we'll see if you decides
to play on it that would be a gutsy
decision considering that laQuan Liam
now has more than double the time on the
clock right but what a win it would be
what a win it would be exactly and no
doubt that thought is flashing through
his head as well what a win it would be
taking out lik when we M
he obviously played a good game to to
get here where he's even got that choice
against against laQuan you know hey do I
do I do this - I do that but a big
decision I think coming up the next move
the next couple moves will tell us
whether Eric's gonna play on the other
thing I'll say is that it's just that
almost the pride of a chess player where
you know you're slightly better and
you're playing a stronger player it's
like are you gonna bend and just take a
draw because a strong player or are you
gonna be honest with yourself and say
well this was a low-rated player I mean
there's no question right i play on I
know I'm better so I think Eric has just
played the move 85 and there you go he's
he's trying to say look being honest
with myself White's better and if he
believes it it's kind of disingenuous
not to not to push the position so so
here we go Penn played a five he's going
for it
against the top seed in the tournament
and he used quite a chunk of his clock
for that move so we'll see if it pays
off for him do you like where Eric is
right - I like where he is on the board
yeah seems to be situated properly it's
well in his chair there yeah I think I
like where he's at there Ben
but a five looks like a very reasonable
move now it looks a little maybe crazy
in some sense like wait a minute I'm
giving up sort of this b5 square for for
the Black Knight and he's been shuffling
there back and forth but the reason I
like this move is that white can now
target that pawn from a safe square like
e - all the way down there maybe even d3
offering exchange of Queens
b7 whatever you can target that pawn and
if black responds with 97 you also have
the Queen b6 square for your queen now
whereas let's say we played Queen e2
here you always have to think about to
move a 5 there's very annoying
undermines your knight there so by
playing a5 he's sort of catching that
before it can happen and yeah Eric's
played a5 I think that's a good move
definitely one of the one of the correct
ones if you want to play for the win so
thankfully you know you don't spend like
15 minutes on your clock and then just
have a horrendous blunder
so that's not happening I think he's on
the right track but it really comes down
to the time pressure cuz look Longley
aminos it slightly
position he's probably gonna be picking
up the pace looking and put Eric under
time pressure all right very well well
we're gonna wrap up the show today here
from st. Louis want a I got a good
question here in the chat asking they
say we have such great content on our
YouTube channel we really do appreciate
that however we miss yasser we'll yasser
be back to do more lectures yasser is
here all the time
he's not scheduled to be a jam and res
coming up but i'd say never say never
especially with yasser he's around here
all the time
I'm sure you'll see more lectures with
him right thank you for joining us
though before we part let's take a look
at our standings in group a this is with
some results pending though and we know
that Jeffrey Zhang and alienation ik are
at the top after their results today and
now Jeffrey Zhang we've seen this before
it we call it the Jeffrey Zhang train
once it gets rolling it's really really
hard to stop and so we might now be on
that locomotive and we will see if
Jeffrey can become a two-time Classic
champion I know we're a ways away I know
I know I know but with Jeffrey it's
never early to start talking right
but then Liam Lee you know this is gonna
be a fun showdown in the later rounds
let's take a look at our standings in
Group B this is with what do we have
okay we have two games still pending by
ginchy theodoro
tied on over at the topic disappointing
day for Gregory right yeah no he he went
down in an any game that looked equal
but I'm quite sure man that there was a
lot more to that than than met the eye
there the space advantage the time
advantage and just the pressure being
put on by by ginchy there so Nicholas
Theodore those seems to be having a
great term in so far and he's up there
with with two wins so he's he's doing
really well they're an international
master obviously looking to
everything for himself the Grandmaster
title and I understand that we're gonna
glance forward a little bit and look at
the pairings for tomorrow group a first
of all group a cousin Jean of Liam Lee
that should be a fun game Colby and
Hanson alright alright I'm digging this
round this is gonna be a lot of fun
tomorrow news Nicky von Schuch what
sticks out to you what are you looking
forward to tomorrow
well another really fun matchup for me
is a Jeffrey Shawn against orient re
that's a battle of two youngsters and on
top of that Jeffrey Jung is on top of
the table right now and tari is actually
still playing his game he's in a rook
end game and orient re if he draws is
still gonna be tied for first and his
game looks like maybe he maybe he has a
chance to win but also a pretty good
chance to draw so that could be a match
between two of the tournament leaders at
the time as well as just two really
talented young grandmasters yeah that'll
probably be our leaderboard key matchup
and our parents tomorrow for Group B
around for action I don't know off the
top my head what will be the leaderboard
key matchup nothing is jumping out right
now well you still have Corollas game
from this round which which needs to
finish and that one has been I mean
Carroll has been playing some weather
he's been on the good or bad side of it
he's been playing some pretty exciting
games and Nicholas Teodoro is atop the
leaderboard so maybe that'll be an
exciting game as he's trying to secure
his his top spot and korilla really has
nothing to lose he's been playing quite
exciting games so far well we'll be back
tomorrow with you at the same time the
same place us chess champs calm
remember the action continues tonight at
us chess champs calm but tomorrow 1:00
p.m. the games for round 4 get underway
and we will be with you two and a half
hours later at 3:30 p.m. this show was
produced by the world's greatest
production B team Tammy Hyatt is your
streamer Danny Machuca the technical
director Isaac Krantz is graphics and
audio and for Grandmaster Aman Hamilton
my name is Ben Simon we will see you
tomorrow right back here we say so long
from the show-me-state
[Music]
this has been a presentation of the st.
Louis chess club
you